[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm your host this week John
Connolly The Spectators news editor
coming up on the show Harry and Megan
are back in the UK next week will drama
following their wake I'll speak to
Freddie gray and Valentine low
there's just a week left of the Tory
leadership contest how is it the race
shaping up James Forsyth and Isabel
Hardman will discuss
less trust made headlines last week for
saying that the jury is still out and
whether Emanuel macron is a friend or
Foe she becomes for KPM what will
British French relations look like I'll
be joined by Simon Cooper and Anne
Elizabeth moutte
Mikhail Gorbachev the last leader of the
Soviet Union died this week I'll discuss
his legacy with Robert service
Louise Perry writes in The Spectator
this week that it's no longer
emasculating to be a stay-at-home Dad
what's changed she'll join me to discuss
and finally wire investment bankers
always portrayed as monsters on screen
I'll speak to Martin Vander Weir about
the TV show industry and his own time in
investment banking
spectator subscription is now better
value than ever as a new subscriber
joining today you'll pay just one pound
a week for unlimited online and app
access in your first year to subscribe
today go to spectator.co.uk forward
slash TV offer and why not subscribe to
our YouTube channel as well click the
Subscribe button button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
Megan and Harrier back in the UK next
week for a string of public engagements
but with a couple having signed a new
Netflix deal Megan's starting a new
podcast and Harry is still barely on
talking terms of his brother how will
they be received the spectators Deputy
editor Freddie gray writes this week's
cover piece about the visit I mean John
joins me now alongside van Time Low the
times role correspondent and author of
the upcoming book cool tiers the hidden
power behind the crown
Freddie Valentine thank you for joining
us on spectator TV now Freddie you write
in this week's cover piece about Harry
and Megan's upcoming trip to the UK
um to start off can you tell us a bit
about the trip what they have planned
well uh let me tell you first about the
sort of the Genesis of this piece
because um I think we first discussed it
in our editorial conference a couple
maybe three weeks ago uh because we knew
that Harry and Megan were planning a
trip uh and we expected there'd be the
usual
um sort of fuss around it and the
antagonisms uh that always seem to
appear uh whenever they are around
um but then as as the weeks went on uh
Megan just kept on giving us more
material and in fact there was almost
too much material uh this week because
um she released the first podcast last
week to put the arch archetypes podcast
from her Archer will audio division uh
and then there was this spectacular
interview this 6 000 word uh
extraordinary profile interview that I
think everybody agrees is one of the
strangest bits of Journalism of the last
few years
uh and then um and then of course
another podcast because these are now
going to be weekly part of this sort of
what people are calling a 12-week war on
the Winds of family disguised as a
podcast
and it's just very interesting and it
it's odd to me that it seems to be Megan
at the moment that's driving
uh the agenda at the moment Harry seems
to be taking a back seat role he appears
he makes sort of guest appearance in the
uh the podcast the first podcast not the
second one and then in this interview he
sort of appears to sort of handyman
around the house talking about fixing
Sprinklers and things
um but it's uh it seems to be the Megan
show at the moment but then there's also
this lurking thing which I'm sure
Valentine will be able to tell us more
about of the book The Harry book that's
coming
um supposed to be by Christmas maybe
delayed now and that's supposed to
contain some real Bombshells that are
going to make life very uncomfortable
for the royal family so they have become
this sort of uh strange Thorn uh in the
monarchy's side and um because they're
coming next week we're going to be
hearing a fair bit more about them
okay and yeah valentine tell us a little
bit about that so we've got a possibly a
Netflix show we've also got Harry's book
I mean do you guys like to get the sense
of what the royal family is most worried
about
uh I think they've braced themselves
um I don't get the sense they're sort of
quaking in their boots because in the in
a way we probably had the worst of it in
the Oprah interview now I think I'm sure
Harry's got more things to say uh but
does he want to completely designate his
relationship with his own family I don't
know uh there's almost a sense that that
Megan is uh more keen to you know pull
him away from his father
there's that key remark in her
interviewing the cut where she said
that Harry said uh uh I I've lost my dad
I'm not sure Harry has completely lost
his father I'm not sure he necessarily
would actually say that because although
relationship sorry although relations
are pretty poor between Harry and
Charles that yeah they can communicate
there is something going on there
um so you know I'm not sure what what
there is to come
um and
what the delay of the book is I don't
know
um we hear all sorts of things I my
guess is and I don't have any great
inside knowledge my guess is we won't
see it this year
um I think it's been pushed back but
um Netflix will presumably be
disappointed about that I mean I think
they would like to have the kind of
symbiotic uh publicity of Netflix uh the
Netflix series and the books that are
feeding off each other and both
promoting each other
um so they would probably like it to be
out this year uh we'll have to see and
um whatever happens it's it's it's going
to be
fairly explosive book very interesting
one because the writer of course he has
got a track record of producing some
fantastically interesting books he did a
biography of Andre Agassi he goes to
agassi's book which was just unlike any
other
um Sports biography really
um so yeah and as for the palace
attitude well more importantly Clarence
House attitude Charles's uh headquarters
attitude I think they they will try and
not rise to the bait
unless Harry says something completely
awful and very specific it's just if
it's more kind of generalized uh slurs
on his father I think they will just do
their very best to keep quiet and not
found the Flames of this very painful
family dispute and Freddie you mentioned
your piece that the book might be
delayed because of a potential class
with Michelle Obama
um do you get the sense that the Obamas
are sort of the the couple that Harry
Megan want to emulate well Harry making
the sort of coming across as a sort of
off-brand of bombers or the Royal brand
if you prefer to look at it that way
Obamas
um they both couples have deals with
Netflix Spotify they have publishing
deals
um and I think Harry and Megan would
like to be like the Obamas in in the
sort of uh the global mind if you'd like
they'd like to be a sort of royalty that
isn't royalty
um imparting wisdom
um and sort of cod spiritualism to every
everyone I don't think they're
succeeding on that front because the
Obamas do seem to be able to produce
content and some people think it's very
good I don't but some people think it's
very good uh and whereas Megan and Harry
seem to have struggled to find the
content that's right for them
archetypes this new podcast uh is does
seem to be a success uh Spotify the
charts show that it's number one it's
been listened to by a lot of people it
seems um we don't quite know how many
people listen to it because they want to
hear it and how many people like me
listen to it because they're masochists
uh but I think the the the sort of
General sense is that they haven't quite
delivered on these very very large
multi-million dollar contracts that they
have from Netflix Spotify uh and the
publishers
and if they if they don't deliver
um then they're going to leave a lot of
people very unhappy and so they have to
give something and I think what's quite
interesting is like uh um Fountain was
saying about the book and the Ghost
Writer
um with the Netflix director they've got
Liz Garbus who's a very sort of highbrow
almost
um director film figure they're not
they're determined to make it look like
they're not doing Keeping Up with the
Kardashians but the Megan and Harry
version
um the trouble is it's a grubby business
people do want uh an insight and Netflix
however much they might try and do
something artistic uh they do want
um the dirt and so does the book uh so
that the Publishers of the book
ultimately so how are they going to walk
this very fine line between sort of
Reinventing themselves uh as an
interesting Obama like couple and also
giving the public the the things that
they probably want which is dirt
ultimately and fans and do you think
they're going to struggle a bit when
that well when runs dry when there are
no sort of more spam handles to say
about the Royal Family do you think
that's their only sort of selling point
or do you think they've got more than
that
well I think we're gonna
archetypes podcast seriously uh quite
closely because I think there was an
interesting difference
between episode one and episode two the
first one about ambition which he spoke
to Serena Williams
basically that was a vehicle for talking
about herself
um and everything she said about and
women and best and ambition was
basically uh talking about Megan and
ambition uh
the one when she spoke to Mariah Carey
about Divas yeah there was a kind of bit
of Megan in there and there was
an exchange where
Mariah Carey called Megan a diva and
Megan pretended uh in this rather
ridiculous way to take it seriously and
be offended but yeah we weren't fool for
a second but there was much more content
uh to that podcast he was less about her
it was more about the subject matter
um so I'm wondering you know as the
podcast series uh goes on whether it'll
move away
um from Megan on to the the people and
the subjects that she's meant to be
talking about uh but yeah they do have
to uh come up with something else
um
the thing about being a member of the
royal family is that people are
interested you just because you remember
the royal family it's a very peculiar
existence uh people have a sort of Sheen
for being rolled even though they're
underneath Underneath It All quite
ordinary human beings
um and once you step away from the
protective Embrace uh of the royal
family and the sort of gloss that it
gives you people do understandably asked
well what is else is there uh now
um yeah
Harry and Megan have tried to show that
there is something else they've done
campaigns in the United States about
vaccination putting it up to countries
that can't afford it uh and their trip
over here is really it's about
self-validation so they're doing a
couple of things they're going to one
young the one Young World Summit uh
where where Megan interesting we're
making speech not Harry here's the role
but he takes us he takes a back seat
that she'll be making the speech and
then
um they'll be at the world chart well
there'll be an Invictus games event in
Germany which is Harry's baby and he
this is him saying listen to Lucas games
I've not left you behind haven't
forgotten about you I'm still behind you
uh and then there'll be a world child
event in in uh in the UK as well and
well child is you know it's a hat it's a
charity that Harry's been very closely
involved with uh and he feels you know
he very sincerely he feels very
passionate about it he he's got a bit
empathy with children he cares a lot
about sick children uh so it does mean a
lot to Harry but this is I
see it as their attempt to remind the
world of their their relevance and
Freddie you know you mentioned at the
beginning there that Harry especially
when it comes to the media world if
maybe not the charity world as much has
been sort of taking a back seat to Megan
do you get the feeling that he's going
to be left out a bit and is maybe a bit
less comfortable producing this kind of
content or a bit less interested in it
has kind of been going to end up being a
bit of a loose end I think perhaps
there's a rather sort of British uh urge
to blame everything on the and probably
no doubt misogynist and possibly even
racist urge to blame everything uh on
Megan the horror wife uh who has taken
over Harry and sort of possessed him uh
I think there's no doubt that she is of
an extremely strong and controlling
personality I think that's obvious to
everyone
um but Harry has gone along with it too
he's the one writing this book he's the
one that uh argued with his family that
split with his family uh they're in this
together and what I think is quite
interesting at the moment is there's a
sort of note of undercurrent of sadness
about everything they do
um because the sort of the words of the
nasty gossip in Hollywood is that they
are they're not very uh loved by the
super a-listers which is what they
desperately want to be they want to be
super a-listers but the the kind of
Hollywood Elite if you like looks down
on them and in fact they found they
found out that um Hollywood can be just
as if not much more nasty Place uh than
the British establishment
um and so you get the impression they're
sort of flitting between these two
worlds the British Monarchy uh and
Hollywood and they haven't really found
a place in either
um perhaps because they muddled what
monarchy is with what celebrity is
um but it's rather a sad story I think
uh and I think it's about to get a bit
sadder and and turning to sort of a bit
of nastiness Valentine I mean some of
the duchess's hardest words in her most
recent interview were towards the
British press I think he said she
wouldn't be able to do the school run
because she'd be hounded every day that
they perhaps use the n-word against her
I mean what did you make of those
comments and and do you think it's going
to make their trip upcoming trip a bit
more difficult
um to answer your question in reverse
order anything to make the uh trip any
more difficult because their relations
of the British media were already at
Rock Bottom they basically think they
can survive without us well perhaps they
can
um so I don't think that matters in the
slightest and what did I make of it well
funny things go on inside Megan's head
um she comes out with stuff
which I don't think she's lying I think
she actually believes it
um but it's total nonsense so the stuff
about
um if she was doing the school run in
Britain there'd be a pen of
photographers all taking Snaps of poor
little Archie
I mean we all know it's total nonsense
Kate takes her kids to school without
there being any photographers there
because there are rules about this stuff
um and
Megan should know that does she know
that or has she forgotten that or does
she
just put everything through the prism of
her beliefs and it just all gets
distorted from her head it's
extraordinary and the idea that someone
or people in the media whether the Royal
rotor or other people or other
Publications I don't know use the word N
word about her children I mean it's
shocking and extraordinary and to the
best of my knowledge is completely
untrue but
I think making somehow believes this
where her belief comes from maybe it
came from that sort of notorious male
online piece very early uh very soon
after Megan's name was first revealed in
public and it did a piece about her
mother and said that Megan was almost
Straight Out of Compton reference of
course to an NWA record
um
and some of that maybe that became
people using the N word about it I don't
know but I think the point is
she believes it all
and she's utterly sincere and perhaps
that's quite worrying brilliant thank
you Valentin and thank you Freddie
in a few days time I'll find out the
winner of the Tory leadership contest
and the next prime minister to discuss
the week in politics I'm joined Now by
The Spectators political editor James
Forsyth an assistant editor Isabelle
Hardman
James Isbell thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um as well starts off so we saw the last
hostings this week between Richie sunac
and Liz truss um do you think we learned
anything new from the candidates in this
one
yeah we did which was quite a surprise
actually so it's quite a jubilant mood
at this hustings I think partly uh
because people are just relieved that
this contest is you know finally over
and also because the party the next
prime minister whichever out of the two
it is uh gets a few days of a sort of
breather before the uh the reality hits
the fan
um to paraphrase a popular saying
slightly and um
so there were some striking things
particularly that Liz trust said uh one
was that she um she wanted to rule out
energy uh rationing which you can sort
of understand why she'd she'd want to
say that that but um it's quite it's
going to be quite a difficult winter and
that this question even came up showed
how difficult um things are going to be
for the new prime minister uh almost
immediately
um and then the other which was really
really interesting was um she was asked
to give a read my lips there will be no
new tax
um no new taxes pledge and she did
indeed rule out uh new taxes which I
think is an interesting promise to make
in the context of
um the conservative party over the past
few years which obviously went into the
2019 general election promising
um no tax Rises and uh lo and behold it
had to abandon that pledge in order to
bring in the Health and Care Levy which
is something that um that Rishi sunak
has has defended passionately throughout
um this campaign and this trust has made
very clear that she uh was was against
and spoke out against in cabinet but
because she's very loyal
um she uh she didn't say anything in
public at the time
um so you know it is going to be a very
difficult few years for uh the new prime
minister and to make that kind of pledge
um before going into office and before
uh seeing all the details which are
going to allow her to or him to make um
a decision on support for households
strug with energy over the winter it's
quite striking
and James you know uh Team Rishi is
saying that the race is possibly still
closer than we think um do you think
there's anything to that
last night
uh obviously the people who go to
hostings you know you you can't say for
certain that they are representative of
the broader membership but I thought the
reception you got last night what was
very positive uh I think you know but I
think the polls are the polls and so you
know we'll all have to wait and see on
Monday but I mean the the polls it would
have to be the most spectacular polling
Miss of of recent times and like Israel
I was very struck when this trust was so
categorical that there would not be
energy rationing this winter
this is something that is being talked
about in other countries and I think the
question away is
it's a reminder that we don't really
know how bad this winter could be
there's a whole spectrum of where it
could land from to you know
uncomfortably High bills but with a
government package to try and uh and
help households with that all the way
through to a situation where there are
blackouts because there simply isn't
enough energy uh to meet demand and I
think this is a reminder of just the
sheer level of uncertainty and the sheer
level of challenge that whoever wins
will face
as well whoever takes the reins as James
says it's a pretty horrific situation
coming up in terms of energy
um has has Liz truss in particular given
any sort of more clues about how she'll
sort of tackle the energy crisis when if
if she comes into Power no she hasn't
and uh she's been
um well very clear that she wants to be
unclear until she gets into Downey
Street and has the full detail so on
this
um both trust and her campaign team who
have sometimes sort of given slightly
different messages of the clarification
from the campaign team after an event
they've been very clear that they're not
ruling anything in or out
um on support for
um people struggling with the cost of
living and again quite a sort of
striking line from truss where she said
that um she doesn't want to uh preempt
what the next Chancellor
um will do and um that this is The
Preserve of the next chance almost as
though you know the workings of the
person she is going to appoint as the
next chance there will be a complete
mystery to her and she hasn't even
thought of who that could possibly be
um or indeed um how they might work
together you know whoever is her next
Chancellor will be answerable to her
um and she's talked a lot about and
wanting to
um I suppose disempower the treasury and
go against the treasury Orthodoxy so
it's not as though she wants to appoint
an over Mighty Chancellor anyway but she
she's basically said that she wants to
wait until she gets into Downing Street
to see all the details
um to see what the Machinery of
government can come up with before
announcing that support in a fiscal
event not an emergency budget but a
fiscal event
um and James you know you're writing
your piece this week in the magazine
about the fact that governments lose
elections not oppositions winning them
um with that in mind how you know would
you be worried taking over the Tory
party at this sort of stage
I think you look at the polls you look
at the fact that labor are now leading
on the economy you know you obviously
have to be worried if you are victorious
and I think that the the the the the
challenge in some ways is that I think
lots of people lots of people on the
tour is like say kirst armor and Davey
are dull they're not charismatic uh they
don't inspire people
but I mean the danger is but those those
weaknesses also mean that people feel
that they're relatively unobjectionable
because they don't generate strong
emotions you won't have what you had in
2019 where lots of Voters went to vote
against Jeremy corbyn and John McDonnell
uh and that is the challenge for the
drawers in terms of how they hold
together their Coalition uh without kind
of Corbin to kind of scare people back
into line and then I think there is also
just the fact that the sheer level of
the challenges that this government is
facing when because it's not just energy
it's the fact that you know and as well
as more expert on this than me given the
book she's currently writing but it's
it's the state of the NHS and I mean the
real worry for whoever comes in is how
much of this has already happened if you
see what I mean how much of uh how much
can you actually realistically do as the
new prime minister to better prepare the
NHS for this winter or are things
essentially already decided before you
even get that and you've just got to
kind of cross your fingers and hope that
it's not particularly cold winter or
where there's not a particularly bad flu
season but you know given what's
happening in Australia you know there
are I think there are worries on that
front and so I think I think this is
this is the the challenge that anyone
taking over the job right now and also
the other challenge I would suggest is
that you have a a predecessor who won't
be shy about making headlines and making
news and you know Boris Johnson is a
celebrity politician and uh whatever he
says in the coming months is going to be
Front Page News
and finally James just to bring it back
to your point before about Boris and how
he's going to be once he leaves number
10. um what do you get the sense of his
relationship is with light with Liz
trust now do you think he's going to be
a pain for her or he's going to try and
be a bit more cooperative
I I don't think he's going to set out
deliberately to cause her problems but I
also think that you know he is going to
be out on the speech making circuit and
you know he will there will be you know
he will say things and they will be
picked up and they will be news and I
also think the only problem is that you
know if you look at uh some of his
partisans in Parliament and some of the
supporters he has in the country it
won't take much for them to start
talking about you know the Tory King
over the water you know you look at this
this membership polling you know if it's
accurate it suggests that he would
handsomely win this contest if he was a
candidate and I mean that that will be a
problem for whoever succeeds him because
when things get tough there will be
people who say oh well why don't we get
Boris back now I think there is a there
is a there is a fundamental problem with
that which is you know the conservative
parliamentary party had so lost faith in
Boris Johnson by the end but everyone
whether Friend or Foe thought that the
the outcome of a no confidence ballot
second and confidence ballot was a
foregone conclusion and so I don't see
that you know I don't mean I don't mean
I don't mean the opinion of MPS is
changing it I I
but I think he will
generate news and that will be
uncomfortable for whoever his successor
is
and thank you James and thank you Isabel
if Liz trust becomes prime minister next
week she wouldn't have gone off to the
best start with the French they should
recently refused to say by the French
President Emmanuel macron was a friend
or Foe but Wilma cronkare and his
relationship between France and Britain
actually better than most people think
Simon Cooper the FD colonist and author
writes in this week's magazine about a
love-hate relationship with the French
and he joins me now alongside the
journalist and Elizabeth moutte
Simon and Elizabeth thank you for
joining us on spectator TV now Simon the
relationship between trust and macron
hasn't got off to the best start already
I mean how do you see their relationship
playing out once um or if trust becomes
PM next week
I think there's two main areas of
contention one is Ukraine and the other
is the Northern Ireland protocol which
is part of the whole brexit argument so
on Ukraine the UK has been very gung-ho
about the war Ukraine is a traditional
Ally of Britain the conservative party
is generally keen on any war and Boris
Johnson didn't really have any other
policies he wanted to do in office so
sort of mobilizing
the sentiment that Britain is still
superpowers very important to him France
is very different on Ukraine France is a
traditional Ally of Russia and mccorn's
Main belief in which I think many
Western European politicians share is
that the invasion of Ukraine is bad it's
sad but it's not really our problem
Russia historically does what it likes
in Eastern Europe which is terrible for
Eastern Europeans but they don't come to
Paris or Rome or Madrid and Macomb wants
to get on with his very long list of uh
reforms of Europe of France and he
doesn't want to spend the next years you
know mired in a cost of living crisis
risk of nuclear war he uh would much
rather shut down this war with a messy
ceasefire as soon as that's possible
that gives
Ukraine that gives Russia a lot of
Ukrainian territory which is what France
did after helped do after the invasion
of Georgia by Russia and after Russia's
invasion of Ukraine in 2014. now so
there's obviously going to be clashes
between France and Britain over this
Northern Ireland protocol is essentially
trust following Johnson's reneging on an
agreement that they signed with the EU
just a couple of years ago and France
like most EU members is hopping mad
about this and sees it as a provocation
and we'll have a fight about this
um and and as Elizabeth do you think
trust was right then to say so Simon
points out there's going to have a few
sticking points there do you think trust
was right to say that the jury is still
out on whether macron is a is a farewell
or an ally
I think she was wrong for several
reasons I think she was wrong because
you don't say that and I admit that the
conditions in which that crazy pub quiz
set up uh was not you know not helpful
and she she shot back and it looked it
showed at the very least a sort of
slight lack of professionalism in sort
of media handling but I also think she's
wrong because I disagree with Simon I
agree with most of he's about to write
for The Spectator I had an early glitch
but I think what Simon what you say
about Ukraine is absolutely true was
absolutely true until about four three
four weeks ago and now that has been a
real U-turn in France in terms of now
trying to work for a a new kind of
Western Alliance Marco has made a number
extremely belligerent and uh bellicose
and very very very sort of strong
statements about Ukraine and about
Russia they're no longer is uh this this
whole General inquiry sort of French of
all saying we want peace as fast as
possible we want to ceasefire totally
neglecting the fact that that would
essentially give Putin what he wants I
also think that France has a good
military class and even though they skew
pro-ruction uh more often than not they
have noticed that Ukraine is actually
winning this war it doesn't mean that
the war is over but you know when when
it was supposed to be a three-day
military operation that would take uh
Kiev uh easily and now there is a
counter-offensive to re-take herself
we're talking about in a tidy different
situation I also think that on this one
um it's it's it's a window of
opportunity because I think the reason
macaw is suddenly being so gung-ho is
slightly uh slightly
self-serving in that yes he realizes I
totally agree with Simon he realizes
that his uh you know this Autumn is
going to be difficult
um cost of living is shot up inflation
has shot up people are angry he has a
fractious Parliament with no clear
majority and therefore what he wants is
to point at the guilty party who's not
him and that's Putin and uh as long as
he does that but you know in a sense
sort of has finally sort of more
honorable attitude for France uh I would
say list trust would really should grab
this with both hands and and uh she
might be able to work out more
understanding on some aspects of brexit
precisely out of brexit dispositions
precisely because she might now be
getting some help on the world stage not
only wants to sort of strengthen the
Western Alliance within NATO he also has
said and his his uh pet thing tankers
have started saying things like they
want they there should be a sort of
extension of what is called the quad
which is a Biden creation uh with um
Australia the US India and Japan and the
idea is to add two Maritime Powers which
are France and Britain and that is
really good a good opportunity to let
bygones for bygones I have noticed that
uh in in in in a week or so there's a
meeting between uh um serious uh um uh
um military leaders between France and
the UK and I suspect that this has got
to do with the fact that Australia has
just realized that getting submarines
delivered in 2014 is not soon enough and
we might see a slight sort of amendment
to the uh uh uh the the sort of the
Fiasco French submarines not being
bought by the Australian government all
of this is very good news because we
need a United West and therefore I'm I'm
more optimistic on on and uh on on what
France could be bringing uh this time
then uh until now the last in the in the
last six months that's a really
interesting point I mean Simon you
mentioned in your piece that a lot of
French hostilities towards brexit is a
little bit about their sort of fear of
frenzy now that Le Pen has been seen off
again my macron do you think there's an
opportunity for a softening of the line
there or do you think that's still not
going to happen
I mean fractured is off the table even
the pen stop proposing it there is no
exit movement in any EU country that I
can see brexit kind of put that to bed
because brexit is not perceived as a
success uh in European countries but I
think that the Europeans are generally
going to remain firm they treasure the
single markets and they don't want
Britain to have access to it if Britain
is not going to observe the full
freedoms that's just it so there is very
little wiggle room it's not like this is
an ongoing negotiation the other thing
is in any field of business if you
become known as a dishonest person who
goes back on his word people are not
going to do business with you that is
true whether you you know deal in wine
or second-hand books or in footballers
if you acquire a reputation for reneging
on your promises people remember that
it's a small circle and Boris Johnson
acquired that reputation having agreed
to the divorce treaty with the northern
protocol just two years later he says
and now his trust says we um we actually
regret it we didn't mean it uh we're
going to unilaterally change parts of it
and whatever the merits of the argument
that ties you as a dishonest broker and
it's not just in France this is a widely
held perception in many European
capitals and in Brussels and I think
that trust by pushing ahead with an
organ Island protocol in Parliament if
they have a huge amount of parliamentary
time that's all it's with the Lords he's
going to keep that front and center and
so she is not doing anything and not
even she wants to do anything to regain
trust in Paris Brussels or elsewhere and
and as bad as Simon says that list trust
is going to revisit the Northern Ireland
protocol do you think that will Define
the relationship as well a bit
yes and honestly it was not something
that the French were thinking about
until it was explained to them and the
first thing was the French are you know
the British sort of model through and
they get somewhere they're very
pragmatic uh the French like a theory
first and then applying the theory and
they could see from the start but the
whole idea about the Border was it was
there was no Theory whatsoever and it
was not going to work and there were
sort of you know interesting words from
Boris Johnson saying we can do this with
modern technology and it came to naught
and the result is that in effect what
was pushed through including up to
inside Michelle valier's office in
Brussels where the British delegation
were fighting among themselves and value
said that he'd never seen anything like
this in his life uh it was it was the
one thing that struck them as something
uh that was uh difficult dangerous and
insulting for any EU country which is uh
Ireland so that thing probably is the
moment where a discretion would be the
best part of valor philistras she's got
to find a different solution she's got
to work it out with you know the the uh
uh the British citizens of Northern
Ireland and and the Republic of Ireland
but it is perfectly true that it's
something that's really caught by the
French and quite understandably you you
if you don't go into something as
difficult as altering the conditions of
a border uh in in the country where
there have been recent uh uh uh troubles
and troubles with euphemism at the time
and it still is today uh it would be it
would be a deal breaker all the things
about you know normal things about
access to the market uh frictionless
sort of visas you know passport whatever
that can be worked out Northern Ireland
is going to be a deal breaker and
honestly it's not it's not the way
Britain wants to sort of close its
relationship with Europe because it's um
it's not going to look good and this is
very true that there's going to be
support from other countries for exactly
the same reasons within the EU thank you
here and Simon has a final thought here
and you kind of ask this question in
your piece it's a very interesting one
um how much do you think the British
French relationship is defined by
leaders and personalities or do you
think the sort of the having the weight
of these two great democracies next to
each other means that they're going to
have a better relationship in future
regardless of who's in charge and
Britain and France have all sorts of
successful daily relationships
you've never in history had two great
capitals so intimately collected
suddenly before the pandemic and we're
starting that again as Paris and London
now the exchange between these two
cities between these two countries
people living and working in each
other's countries is almost unparalleled
in the world you have a huge amount of
trade none of that is going to go away I
mean this is in the Bronze Age people
were taking boats from what is now
northern France to Southern England and
back in a day of course they did they
had more contact if you lived on the
French Coast in the north with people in
what is now England than they did with
people in the French interior who are
much harder to reach so you know Prime
Ministers come and go in Britain a rapid
clip nowadays and it of course there's
all sorts of daily arguments it doesn't
make much difference and as I see it's
remarkable as I say it's remarkable that
two ambitious military Powers separated
by 20 miles of water have not fought for
200 years it's a very good relationship
brilliant thank you Simon and thank you
and Elizabeth
on Tuesday the last leader of the Soviet
Union Mikhail Gorbachev died to discuss
his influence character and career I'm
joined by the esteemed historian of the
Soviet Union Robert service
Robert thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um Mikhail Gorbachev died this week aged
91 you know arguably one of the most
important figures in Soviet Union's
history
um how would you sort of evaluate his
his life and Legacy
well he destroyed the Soviet Union so
that's a great thing that's a fantastic
achievement he didn't mean to do it
uh but he did eventually come round to
thinking that really basic reforms of
Communism were necessary that would make
communism not really like communism
anymore he became a sort of Social
Democrat
and that's that's a that that's um an
amazing
self-transformation and along with it he
brought the country so he took Russia
towards
democracy almost not in tending to do it
at various stages but he pushed himself
forward
he obviously thought himself to be a man
of Destiny and it
you know if anyone was in the 20th
century I think he was he was a great
man
and what are your kind of memories of
that time as sort of the the years
towards the sort of collapse of the
Soviet Union and Gorbachev's time as uh
as leader
well sadly
um great man though he was
he was instrumental in destroying the
economy
on an economy that was already in very
60 decline but I do remember at the end
of 1990
going into a dairy Supermarket we don't
have them in the UK or anywhere else in
the world
and there were a dozen or two dozen very
well dressed white uniform Dairy
assistance
and in the whole of this huge building
this huge Dairy Supermarket there wasn't
a single half liter of milk that was no
yogurt there was nothing to sell apart
from some old packets of tea
now that
that really brought it home to me a year
before the Soviet Union felt that this
economy was
was going down that had gone down the
drain and it had taken the milk with it
um because I wonder so Gorbachev doesn't
have a particularly good
um reputation inside Russia he's blamed
a lot for the economic catastrophe that
followed the Soviet Union's collapsed do
you think do you think he's been a bit
unfairly maligned do you think it was it
was always going to happen that way or
do you think he Bears more
responsibility than that
I think he had the the mouse
the wisdom
to see
that something really drastic needed to
be done and he did a lot of the DraStic
necessary things but the one thing he
just could not bring himself to do
was introduce a a full or even semi-full
market economy and that was that was
going to be the only thing
that saved the Russian people and that's
what they hold against it he in mrated
his own people by his policies and
there's been a lot of talk over the last
couple of days about Yeltsin
and it's been deprecatory talk
uh and huge corruption took place on the
under yelts and there's no doubt about
it
but he did have the guts to introduce
some kind of market economy and
Gorbachev
just couldn't bring himself to do that
um
and looking a bit at the sort of the
satellite states that broke away from
the Soviet Union
um how big consistent do you think it
was that the Gorbachev kind of didn't
send in the Army to places like Hungary
and Czechoslovakia it's obviously had
been done before
um how big how how surprising or big a
move do you think that was
it it was a
a bold political decision it did get in
a lot of criticism in the armed forces
in particular
uh and in the new Congress of people's
deputies that's certainly true but we
have to bear in mind that Russia was
bankrupt it couldn't it couldn't support
financially
a military uh intervention
had a moral inhibition about intervening
in any case in a political
inhibition but I don't think he could
have done it
in any case Russia was was on its knees
in 1989 1990
and but he did send the Army into the
Baltic so can you maybe talk us through
about sort of why he made that decision
and after choosing not to intervene
elsewhere because I think you sort of
look at it and you think well why why
didn't he send the Army into one but not
the other kind of thing
that's a really interesting point John
um his closest a uh Anatoly chernierev
used to say that he had a thing about
the Baltic states that he just couldn't
see them as being foreign countries he
had a sort of fixed picture of what
the Soviet Union was and he couldn't see
it as being an Empire
which was trapping countries against
their will
inside it and
this was another of his inhibitions this
is another of his failings for all of
his greatness this was a man with huge
intellectual flaws
um do you sort of seem as quite a tragic
figure of History almost in the sense
that his reforms opened up the Soviet
Union but then also brought the end to
it
yes
um he obviously thought of himself as
having failed in in that respect but
um I think I've read all of the no he
kept on writing memoirs some of which
added a little each time
took the record
I think he
he didn't feel that he was tragic
um in as much as he thought that he had
given Russia in particular the chance of
having Freedom if it really wanted to to
take it and keep it
um I don't think he can be blamed for
Putin
um
Johnson it was who who gave the Throne
of power to Putin
um and
implicitly regretted it very quickly
afterwards
you know one thing about garbage off I
really think people
ought to know and that was his
down-to-earthness I remember going to a
conference
where there was a coffee break
and a big cue and he was ushered to the
front of the queue and he refused to
stand at the front he took his
um position
uh at the back and waited his turn and
was jabbering away to the person in
front of him and the person behind him
just like an ordinary uh an ordinary
chat and that that really impressed me
it that wasn't put on he he had a a
decent down to earth
signed to him
right I wasn't down to earth enough to
understand
what damage he was doing to ordinary
people's cost of living conditions
am I right Robert in saying that you met
him as well in the 1990s
yes I did
what was your impression of them
I had a chat with him
um and it was going very well I thought
um
very smoothly
until he in those days I was writing a
biography of Lenin
whom he adore
and uh
you probably weren't quite as
sympathetic
[ __ ] he said
he's
saying
Lenin actually
um and he immediately
close the conversation down found some
someone else to talk to it was too
embarrassing for him he knew this for a
touchy subject in the west I think it
was
[Music]
um
another flaw in his thinking he could
never get away from the fact that if
only he did things the way that Lenin
had done in the last years of Brennan's
life then everything would be hunky-dory
in the Soviet Union this is sheer
Madness absolute Madness
and there's a fascinating character I
mean you mentioned this humility I mean
am I right and say he came from quite a
humble background himself what's his
sort of rise up the ranks in the Soviet
party kind of purdained or does it sort
of involve quite an impressiveness on
his part
no he was a very talented very very
bright man and as a young boy
came from a collective Farm
in the south of uh Russia his family had
suffered in the Australian repressions
uh he suffered during the German
occupation during the second world war
but his teachers spotted something
really outstanding and he went to
um the law faculty at Moscow State
University this is like being pulled
pulled out of
nowhere and going to uh well let's let's
say Oxford or
uh Cambridge or Yale or
Stanford
um so he he suddenly had this chance
to to move out of
The Village
and um
build a build a new career for himself
that none of his fellow villagers had
ever had
um
um and and he remembered conditions in
the village he wanted to do something
about Soviet agriculture it just didn't
he just didn't have enough
to
um
decollectivize
uh agriculture it would have been a very
very tough thing to do but that's what
has been necessary I mean why is it that
Ukraine became the Bread Basket of
[Music]
um
the Mediterranean
in the early 2000s it was because they
decollectivized before that Ukraine was
a an economic basket case
so not enough ideological flexibility
from him in the end
brilliant thank you very much Robert
that was absolutely fascinating
brilliant uh good to speak to you
Louise Perry writes for The Spectator
this week that more and more men are
choosing to be stay-at-home dads a lot
of the reason she says is to do with
class to explain it Louise joins me now
Louise thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you write for The Spectator this week
about how stay-at-home dads are becoming
a bit of a status symbol can you um tell
us a little bit about that please
so my reasoning is this right we've seen
this really interesting Trend in the
last 20 years where it used to be that
um men who did Blue Collar jobs did more
child care on average than men who did
White Collar jobs and then we've seen a
precise reversal since the turn of the
century
combined with the fact that at the same
time we've seen
middle class parents adopting a kind of
parenting which is extremely intensive
right we're talking
Montessori no screen time you know
organic food The Works everything that
takes a lot of a lot of time from
parents and which ideally also
particularly with something like
attachment parenting which is kind of
extreme end of that
encourages parents to do Child Care
themselves as much as possible and to
you know sustain things like daycare and
focus much more on being at home with
their children in a really sort of the
way I describing the piece is sort of
like cultivating rare orchids right
that's the kind of aspirational model of
parenting now
and my reasoning is looking at these two
Trends and looking around me as well
because we live in a very bougie suburb
of London and we've just had a baby and
we've got loads of friends who are
having babies and so on and
the dads of our acquaintance are
extremely Hands-On right that's the
phrase that my that my parents used to
use I think we don't hear it as much now
because it's now sort of taken as red
you might still have say Jacob Brewery
smog boasting about the fact that he's
never changed to nappy but I don't think
any of the men that we know in our
Circle would be caught dead admitting
that they'd never change to nappy that's
just taken has been you know that's the
assumption that you will be hands on
right from the right from the very
beginning and you'll actually be quite
sort of sometimes a little bit
ostentatious about how much you do
um including things like cooking
cleaning you know the works doing all
the all of the um what used to be
considered women's work
and I think the reason for this has a
lot to do with status I mean part of it
I'm sure is to do with men acting out of
the goodness of their own hearts and
genuinely wanting to spend time with
their children I mean that was something
that came out of the pandemic that a lot
of fathers were spending more time at
home because of working from home and
actually found they actually like their
kids they actually like being with their
kids which is obviously all you know all
to the good but I also think that we
have to think a little bit about about
how status and class feeds into all of
this you know it used to be
it was really difficult
following the second wave to to get dads
to do more women's work right it was
never difficult to persuade women
particularly middle class women to do
Men's Work If by that we mean the kind
of going out and doing professional job
and having all the income and status
that comes with doing that the women
were queuing up to do that that was no
problem what was difficult though was
persuading men to take on the
traditional feminine roles which was why
we ended up with what sociologists call
the second shift where women would go
out and they'd spend all day at work and
then they'd come home and they still
have to do all the all the cooking all
the laundry much more Joker than their
husbands were doing and so on which
obviously made women exhausted and
miserable and grumpy
um I think that that might starting to
that might be starting to change I think
that we're seeing more I mean men are
doing records amount of child care you
know since records began particularly as
as I said the men doing White Collar
jobs and we're also seeing
um this stuff no longer being considered
quite as low status it's no longer just
kind of the women's work the girly work
that you that you have to sort of argue
over who has to do it it's becoming I
think much more of a sign of being
um a really good parent to be really on
board with doing all of this stuff even
to the extent that I think the
stay-at-home dad who is obviously the
most the most extreme manifestation of
this kind of approach I think the
stay-at-home dad he's still a rarity not
as not nearly as rare as he once was
still a rarity but I think as time goes
by he could become much more of a status
symbol
particularly because it is now so much
more difficult for families to live on a
single income combined with the fact
that doing the Intensive kind of
Hands-On dad stuff is associated with
with the upper middle classes right
I think just on a purely economic level
there's no better way of telling
everyone that you're minted than having
a dad stay at home right far better than
skiing holidays and work shows and so on
so I think just purely based on the
status game the stay-at-home diet is
definitely here to stay that's very
interesting and so you mentioned there
so childcare used to be seen as a bit
emasculating a bit more of women's work
do you think that's completely gone and
and and if it's maybe not gone and sort
of the middle of classes do you think I
think it's maybe still there and in
lower classes for example working class
it is still definitely the case that
women do a lot more of that work and I
think it it's definitely the case that
it's considered
um in general to be lower status even if
that's starting to
shift I mean you see this all the time
in how women speak about their work you
know particularly women in professional
jobs where
um it's kind of taken as red that you'll
want to do you'll want to sort of
cultivate the professional side of your
life and just stay in the domestic side
of your life because that's just the
lowest latest thing you know it's kind
of a no-brainer it's always interesting
I think to look at polling on how women
actually feel about this and and it's
surprisingly common to find women
particularly women who don't do
if you don't have degrees who aren't
doing kind of interesting High status
professional work
um who actually much prefer the work of
the home if given the choice despite the
lower status attached to it so I think
the thing is that this stuff is
this stuff is vulnerable to to cultural
change because you know on the face of
it staying home with your children all
day versus going to the office there's
nothing inherently Better or Worse about
either of those options it kind of
depends on temperament and your
conditions and so on but there are
plenty of people who if if the economic
factors were taken out and if the status
factors were taken out would happily
choose a former and some of those people
will be men so I can I can readily
imagine a situation where if we if we
kind of if there was a collective shift
in how we regard that kind of work work
of the home you could definitely see
more men adopting it as well as not
women
and do you think it's good for children
though we're seeing a bit more few more
men sort of take on roles at home
yeah I think so I mean I write in the
piece about the fact that my my husband
works four days a week so he's at home
um with our son today in fact today is a
daddy day
um and it's really lovely actually
because I think our son has a much
closer relationship than he would
otherwise I think that kind of Frosty
father model of the past
um
it's definitely unfashionable and I
think that's probably a good thing
Yeah you mentioned the piece that Dennis
Thatcher your I think your husband
describes as a Chad is that right I mean
do you think Dennis was ahead of his
time
well I wonder how we have how we found
at the time I mean it was kind of it was
extremely unusual position to be forced
into right the thing that made me think
about it is uh reading um Hamish badenox
diary in The Spectator a few weeks ago
where he wrote about the experience of
being
of of of almost being husband to the
Prime Minister
um and you know the being in the shadow
of the successful successful female
politician which of course Dennis
Thatcher he dealt with that many decades
before and uh yeah as far as as far as I
can tell dealt with it dealt with it
masterfully
um I don't think there's anything I
think a man who has sufficient
confidence and a man who is sufficiently
masculine in other areas of his life can
definitely be be done a Snapchat and be
a child at the same time well on that um
you mentioned in your piece about the
fact that there was an advert that was
pulled by I think was by Hoagies about
that would mocked dads for being a bit
incompetent and how that would be sort
of Unthinkable today do you think dads
are being a bit too sensitive about this
and deserve to be you know deserve a bit
of a ribbing at least still
oh well I mean I think everyone just you
know everyone should be made fun of
absolutely everything right it is really
interesting though that the um the
incompetent dad thing was a really
durable comedic Trope
um not just in advertising but in I mean
the whole point of advertising jokes is
their sort of lowest common denominator
jokes right that they're designed to be
as appealing as possible to as many
people as possible so they're quite an
interesting route therefore into
understanding culture and yeah the
incompetent bad thing
um came up a lot I suppose because you
can't really make fun of
um making fun of women for being
competent mothers isn't as funny as I
think it's more tragic and you also
can't make fun of women for being
incompetent in the workplace because
that's definitely too much of a source
ball like you definitely get angry
letters for doing that so I suppose the
incompetent dad was the only safe option
um and now but now increasingly it isn't
I do yeah Huggies got had to pull their
ads
um about
obvious that the premise of the ad was
that the dads had to be like confined to
a house just with other dads and their
babies for five days and presumably keep
the keep the children alive was like the
goal the goal of the challenge
um and apparently no one found it very
funny so
brilliant thank you very much Louise
and finally a new series the HBO show
industry is coming out in the UK soon
Martin vanderwear The Spectators
business editor speaks to the show's
creators in this week's magazine and
asked whether it's fair that investment
bankers are always portrayed as monsters
on screen to discuss Martin joins me now
Martin thank you for joining us on
spectator TV it's a pleasure thank you
um you're right in the magazine this
week well you interview the creators of
the HBO show industry
um to start us off so how does sort of
their portrayal of investment banking
sort of compare with yours
with my experience of it well I left
investment banking
actually 30 years ago but I did catch
the sort of first wave of the uh
development of big trading flaws and a
sort of more Macho uh Ambiance and
screens everywhere and people shouting
and uh a new culture of sort of uh
selfishness and aggression you might say
that came with the big money that that
arrived in the investment banking scene
in the second half of the 1980s it began
and it began with a sort of influx of
American firms into London so naturally
enough I have a particular fascination
with how it how that world is portrayed
in fiction on screen in novels and so on
uh and I thoroughly enjoyed industry but
one of the things I thought about it and
friends of mine who are still in that
world tend to agree with me is that it's
pretty authentic I mean it looks like a
real trading floor even though it's
actually built in a old television
Factory in Cardiff of all places but it
looks right the people look right they
talk the language correctly if you care
to sort of uh you know listen carefully
to what they're saying about financial
markets it all kind of makes sense so I
think it's particularly good portrayal
there have been some absolutely bizarre
and Wild Ones Like the Wolf of Wall
Street
um or American Psycho the the
um uh anti-hero in that is an investment
banker of some sort isn't it but this
one I thought felt it felt very real
yeah I mean so you mentioned in the
piece that the show has lots of
manipulation backstabbing there's no
very likable characters do you think
that's kind of accurate as well and kind
of kind of sums up the culture
well no and the two writers Conrad K and
Mickey down they're one of the first
things they admitted was actually they
really they were both investment bankers
one
um Mickey was at Rothschild doing
mergers and Acquisitions and Conrad was
at Morgan Stanley as an equity salesman
and they both disliked their jobs
because they felt they were you know
they actually used the phrase imposter
syndrome they felt they really weren't
on top of the job and one day they were
going to be found out uh so they were
kind of uncomfortable they but they
admitted they did like their colleagues
or some of them and there was some
camaraderie and they did go to the pub
on a Friday and so on and I I could say
the same thing I still you know 30 years
later I'm in touch with quite a number
of people I worked with in that world
who I was fond of them and I'm fond of
now but there was also a sort of
horridness about it that because it was
so competitive and there was so much
money at stake you know you could then
just beginning now you know just as a
matter of normal form you could earn a
life-changing bonus in a single year but
you had to compete like a Savage
um to do that so people's behavior
changed they became less trusting of
colleagues altogether less Collegiate
and certainly much less loyal to the
employer the employer
was there to be sort of gamed for you
know three to five years Maximum take as
much as you could out in in bonuses and
move to the next employer was the
General was the general form so it's a
kind of
there are some very unattractive aspects
to the the arena but of course there are
as everywhere nice people as well as uh
horrid people
and do you think the um the culture
changed around sort of 2008 and the
financial crash or do you think that was
more from the from the public sides and
asked you to bankers
I think that's more on the public side
uh in the sense that I think the uh
the core of the financial World bounced
back pretty rapidly I mean we can all
remember that famous bit of news video
of people leaving the Lehman building
with their cardboard boxes well some of
those people will have gone and grown
organic vegetables or you know uh become
stand-up comedians but a lot of them
will have got jobs back in the financial
well they were back on a trading floor
somewhere within a few months or a year
or two and it all carries on and you
know new new Financial gimmicks and
instruments are invented new ways of
making money all the time
um say now what's surprising is how how
much the same it is even looking as far
back as my
time my limited and rather unhappy time
on trading floors more well over 30
years ago now it's the same
it's the same mechanisms of human nature
at work
right and are there sort of different
sort of cultures and attitudes on
different floors and sections of the
bang for example like on trading or on
the investment side and that kind of
thing and the particular notorious
departments Maybe
well so I think actually I could see the
contrast between Conrad who'd been an
equity salesman so he's sitting there
cold calling clients trying to sell them
stuff he he was admitting to me he
didn't really understand what he was
trying to sell and Mickey who had been
an analyst as a sort of backup to a team
of people trying to do mergers and
Acquisitions deal that's a much more
cerebral intellectual end of investment
banking and I think in the series
um
the the right at the beginning of the
first series there's a guy who dies in
the office because he's so stressed out
and so overworked and I think he's one
of the people who's coming to work all
night doing analysis of companies for
pitches for deals and so on that was
rather where I was at a certain point of
my career and it was pretty awful the
trading floor on the other hand was
livelier more fun had a lot of banter
um a lot of machismo a lot of
testosterone flying around
and you know share share aggression and
moment to moment changes of markets were
what
did and still drive people's excitement
on trading floor so that's that's the
contrast but the the real monsters
tended to be on the trading floor and
the Really clever people tended to be
doing the m a deals and other other
kinds of complex deal making Martin's
others obviously is a TV show but there
are also lots of portrayals of sort of
sex and drugs and that kind of thing um
do you think do you think that goes on
or do you think that's a bit of just a
glamorization of TV well I've been
asking around about that whether you
know so what I can say is from my era uh
I certainly never encountered um cocaine
in the office or out of it to be
perfectly honest but I think there
probably is a lot of that about these
days uh the the there is quite a high
quotient of of sex in the show and and
the boys told me that there could be
even more in the second series because
the backers of it told them to you know
up the kind of shagging quotient rather
than reduce it
um the the fact is in that world there
was a always a sort of rather sexually
charged atmosphere there are a lot of
you know young and energetic people uh
kept in a sort of enclosed space working
very long hours and naturally enough for
the you know the 20-somethings and the
30-somethings that was often uppermost
in people's minds and you know of course
I don't remember it being quite like
that in my era but some of my friends
tell me actually it was
anyway uh it it adds to the
entertainment of the series there's no
doubt about it but they one one of my
Chums is still in that world said to me
maybe one thing about the series that
isn't quite right is they seem to party
almost every night whereas in reality
those kids nowadays they work such long
hours that they probably party very hard
on a Friday and a weekend but on weekday
nights they're too exhausted for all
that stuff so it kind of you know it's a
slightly exaggerated version of reality
but it is it is very entertaining and I
think it's I I say hats off to them for
the authenticity and I did ask them
whether this was all a kind of on the on
the psychiatrist couch thing where
they're trying to work it out of their
system
um but I think they've probably gone
beyond that it took me a while to work
it out of my system I wrote a terrible
unpublished Thriller about Investment
Banking and then I became a journalist
writing about him right about nothing
else for the first few years but it you
know we all have to get it out of our
systems
brilliant thank you very much Martin
that's it for this week remember if you
enjoy what we do here at The Spectator
you can subscribe to the magazine and to
our online content join today and you'll
pay just one pound a week for unlimited
online and app access in your first year
to subscribe go to spectator.com
TV offer
and don't forget to subscribe to The
Spectators YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]